[Music]
happy comic-con week everyone we just
got our Marvel phase 4 panel and Kevin
Feige just revealed everything you could
ever possibly want we have confirmed
x-men coming confirmed Fantastic Four so
I'll break everything down they even
showed off a bunch of footage from
everything but we have our entire Marvel
phase 4 schedule through 2021
meaning that some of the other stuff
they revealed like the blade movie that
they're making with Maher Sheila Ali is
going to be during Marvel phase 5
[Applause]
it looks like it looks like you brought
your own hat rehearsal you did what is
that
[Applause]
so a lot of the stuff is also Marvel
phase five I'll try to distinguish
between what's phase four and what's
phase five because this news is so
awesome we're doing a new round of that
Avengers endgame blu-ray giveaway
because I was getting ready to come out
all you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and leave your favorite
Avengers moment on the video or the
moment that you're most looking forward
to during Marvel phase four so first
things first you're asking what's going
on with Fantastic Four and x-men Kevin
Feige confirmed that they are in
development he didn't say exactly when
the movies are going to come out but it
sounds like Fantastic Four is going to
come out before x-men which makes sense
it's what you would call a distressed
property like if you're into fixing
houses up it's the broken house that's
way more broken than the x-men house and
because Dark Phoenix just came out and
there's way more x-men films than there
are Fantastic Four they're just gonna
give it a little bit longer to cool off
before they reboot all the characters
all of that is spoilers but I'm
extremely excited about those characters
and about and about bringing Marvel's
first family up sort of to the platform
and the level that they deserve they
didn't announce any cast or anything
like that like I used the John Krasinski
mr. fantastic picture just because it
looks so fantastic but they haven't
officially confirmed who's going to be
playing their Fantastic Four characters
rumor right now is that it's going to be
released during 2022 at some point and
it's gonna be directed by Peyton Reed
who did both of the ant-man movies
ant-man and ant-man and the wasp but
this is the picture of the official
Marvel phase 4 schedule through 2022
there are 10 projects that they
confirmed during Marvel phase 4 over the
course of the next two years meaning
that Marvel phase 4 itself won't last
that long but there is a ton of stuff
happening during it that includes both
of the movies and the TV shows that
they're doing based on the Avengers
characters like the Loki show Scarlet
Witch envisioned the Captain America
Falcon in Winter Soldier series with
Baron Zemo
they even confirmed a Hawkeye series so
I'll just break this down going through
the Marvel phase four schedule is
actually really really exciting and you
probably want Disney Plus if you didn't
want it before
because some of the series will tie in
with the movies but it'll all make sense
once I explain it so no worries breaking
it down top
ten style starting with number ten black
widow that's the next movie that's up
they showed off a trailer I'll break
that trailer down tomorrow because
that's like a whole big separate set of
footage but they confirmed the
taskmaster is the main villain they
confirmed the David Harbor from stranger
things that you probably just saw is
playing Alexi aka red Guardian from the
comics so he's not the main villain he's
not playing taskmaster somebody else's
the movie is confirmed to be taking
place after Captain America Civil War
but before the events of Avengers
infinity war because she still has red
hair I'll talk about that more during
the trailer video but the movie also
stars Rachel Wiest they didn't say who
she's playing but probably a fairly big
figure in black widows life Ray Winstone
they didn't say who he's playing but
obviously Florence Pugh is playing
yelling at Bulova the other version of
Black Widow they have a really badass
fight scene during the trailer that they
showed off in Hall H the movie is gonna
be a little bit more like their version
of a Bourne movie or a John wick movie
so if you really like John wick fighting
style it's gonna be a lot like that
during Black Widow 9 next up after that
the Eternals movie is dated November 6
2020 there are only two big Marvel films
that are gonna be happening next year
but Kevin Feige said the turtles will be
something that's entirely new for them
they've done a little bit of Eternals
back story through Thanos in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe but not in a really
big way but he did say it would be very
inspired by Jack Kirby big and weird
like they did during Thor Ragnarok with
all the Kirby designs that you saw all
over the place they'll deal with the
Celestials the characters will be
immortal in the context of the Marvel
Cinematic Universe they've been around
this whole time we just haven't known
about them they confirm Richard Madden
is gonna be playing Icarus one of the
main characters salma hayek
is gonna be playing their leader Kumail
Nanjiani is in the movie they didn't say
who he's playing Bryan Tyree Henry is
playing Blastoise Angelina Jolie is
playing FINA and Gong Li is playing
Gilgamesh their more characters than
that but those are the only people they
brought out on stage number eight right
after that in the schedule is the Falcon
Winter Soldier show on Disney Plus
coming fall 2020 so maybe like an
October release date next year Anthony
Mackie has already had his first costume
fitting for his version of the Captain
America suit so he will be Captain
America during the events of the series
he even brought Captain America shield
out on stage with him at Comic Con they
played a little teaser clip from
Brule with the purple mascot from the
comics as Baron Zemo so he's going full
comic book during the series but the
teaser went like this so Baron Zemo is
showing this clip as if he's leaving it
for Falcon and Winter Soldier like he's
coming for them it begins with the code
words that activate Winter Soldier and
Baron Zemo sits on this frame wearing a
coat looking all ragged with a beard
he says he's hijacked their Comic Con
panel and says gentlemen I will be
seeing you very soon then puts on the
purple mask from the comics in the video
cuts out so I feel like definitely a
path the Thunderbolts through that TV
show but remember even though it's a big
part of Marvel phase 4 that's the first
Disney Plus streaming service show 7
next up is shang-chi February 12 2021
they confirmed the title is shang-chi
and The Legend of the ten rings
confirming that the Mandarin is going to
be the main villain the real Mandarin
that you got a taste for in that Iron
Man 3 one shot I'll do a separate video
about that some other time all hail the
king because it's probably been a while
since a lot of people have seen that
they announced the shang-chi actor C mu
Lee oh he's a relatively unknown actor
you may have seen him in a couple of
smaller things but he's from Canada then
they also announced that aquafina from
crazy rich Asians and a whole bunch of
other stuff is gonna be part of the
movie too but they didn't say who she's
going to be playing or what time period
the movie's gonna take place during but
I'm assuming it's taking place during
the present day after Avengers end game
6 next up on the schedule is one
division The Scarlet Witch in vision
series that's gonna be spring 2021 so
I'm guessing sometime around April it's
only gonna be six episodes long but
it'll make sense why that is in just a
minute it's set after the events of
Avengers endgame Elizabeth Olsen said
the show's gonna be really weird deep
and fun it will find out exactly why
she's called Scarlet Witch and that's
talking about more her chaos magic from
the comics so if you've been waiting for
magical Scarlet Witch in the MCU it
sounds like they're going full
comic-book scarlet witch Paul Bettany
also joked I'm not sure if I'm alive on
this show because vision is still dead
as of the end of endgame so presumably
they repair him and bring him back to
life at the beginning of the series
they also cast Monica Rambeau as an
adult for the series so I don't know if
they're gonna do photon Monica Rambeau
but she's being played by this actress
here maybe you've seen her before but
they didn't say exactly
mónica Rambo's plot is going to be
during the series only that she's going
to be a part of it
five right after that the Loki series is
also going to premiere spring 2021 so
pretty close to when they're premiering
the Scarlet Witch TV show they confirmed
that it's going to be the Loki from
Avengers endgame that took the tesseract
and ran so it'll be the alternate
timeline version of Loki that just got
his ass handed to him by Hulk remember
the Marvel multiverse is real they
established it in the first Doctor
Strange movie and now we have alternate
timeline multiverse versions of
characters running around
Loki being one of them it'll make sense
why they're doing that in a second
because number four they announced the
Doctor Strange sequel is going to come
out May 7th 2021 in the title is Doctor
Strange in the multiverse of madness
meaning it'll be a proper multiverse
movie it's also supposed to be Marvel's
first legit horror film and it's gonna
star Scarlet Witch teaming up with
Doctor Strange so when I said full comic
book Scarlet Witch with her chaos magic
that's where this comes in nightmare is
the confirmed villain there was a teaser
from a year or two ago that the director
dropped I'll do a separate video about
that at some point next week because
there's so much to talk about then right
after the events of the Doctor Strange
movie summer 2021 is when they're
premiering the what if Marvel TV series
it'll start all the MCU actors coming
back to voice their characters in
different episodes but it's going to be
animated so they'll be just doing voices
for their characters in jeffrey wright
from Westworld is going to be doing the
voice of the watcher narrating each of
the episodes so even though the watchers
already exist in the MCU we're actually
gonna get the main version of the
watcher that we typically interact with
interacting with the MCU characters
three they confirm the Hawkeye series is
real it's gonna premiere fall 2021 so
sometime October 2021 they didn't say
how many episodes but they're using the
fraction Hawkeye logo they said that it
would deal with more of his time as the
Ronin character so that means Kate
Bishop Hawkeye during the series two
basically doing their own version of the
map fraction Hawkeye run so if you
haven't read it check it out it's
awesome I've already done a couple
videos about it it's basically Hawkeye
training the next version of Hawkeye
Kate Bishop will eventually take the
mantle enjoying the Young Avengers
- closing down Marvel phase four is Thor
for which I've already done a video
about the title for that is love and
thunder I love the logo there are so
many things that they're doing with this
movie so they confirm Valkyrie is coming
back she'll be big character but they're
also doing Jason Erin's Mighty Thor run
which means that they're doing the
female version of Jane Foster Thor with
Natalie Portman they even brought
Natalie Portman out on stage and she
held Thor's hammer so at some point she
will gain the powers of Thor but I don't
know if they're gonna do the cancer plot
or how that's going to work so I'm
assuming it's gonna be changed quite a
bit I'll do a separate video about that
because there's just so much to unpack
in all the things that they announced
they just unveiled pretty much
everything that's happening for the next
four to five years but number one the
biggest things that they dropped are
that they do have a Fantastic Four movie
coming they do have an x-men movie
that's coming they just called it a
blank title of mutants so there's no
official title for what that first x-men
movie is going to be but then they
brought Maher Sheila Ali out on stage
and revealed that he's going to be doing
a blade movie inside the MCU they didn't
say when it's going to happen so I'm
assuming sometime after 2022
I'm sure Wesley Snipes will be involved
with it in some way but they just
brought him or her Sheila out on stage
and they just took his hat off oh wow
he's wearing a blade hat that means that
he is blade in the MCU now they also
confirm Black Panther two guardians of
the galaxy vol 3 but they didn't say
exactly when those movies are gonna come
out so it'll be after 2021 for that
other stuff including Fantastic Four in
x-men everybody freaked out in the
comments let me know what you're most
excited about and let me know what you
want them to do with that x-men movie in
with that Fantastic Four movie my next
video will probably be a breakdown of
that Black Widow trailer that should be
up in the morning and then there's a
whole bunch of other DC trailers that
drop too so I'll do videos for that
stuff in the next couple of days as long
as you have alerts enabled for my
channel you'll see all the videos when I
post them all name a giveaway winner
when I post that next video but click
here for my spider-man far from home and
credits fantastic for Easter Egg video
doesn't that make more sense now and
click here for the brand-new Rick and
Morty season 4 trailer thank you so much
for watching everybody stay awesome
happy Comic Con week
[Music]